Escribe la ecuación de la línea que tenga
la pendiente de 1/3 y que contenga el punto,
-12, -14/3.
Y bueno, la forma de la recta que voy a escoger
es la siguiente,
"y" es igual a "mx" más "b", la cual es la forma pendiente ordenada al origen, donde "m" es la pendiente
y "b" es la ordenada al origen o la intersección
con el eje de las yes.
Y bueno, ¿ y qué datos nos dan?
Lo que nos dan de datos es que mi recta tiene
la pendiente de 1/3, por lo tanto,
"m" vale 1/3 y esta ecuación la puedo reescribir de
la siguiente manera,
"y" es igual a 1/3 de "x" más "b"
Y bueno, lo siguiente que me dan es un punto
y entonces para que yo descubra el valor de
"b", voy a utilizar este punto que me dan,
que por cierto, lo que nos dice es lo siguiente,
que cuando "x" vale -12, "y" vale -14/3...
cuando "x" vale -12, "y" vale
y déjame ponerlo aquí, -14/3.
Y entonces, ya que tengo estos dos datos,
voy a sustituir los respectivos valores,
tanto de "x" como de "y" y entonces me queda que
-14/3 es igual a 1/3 de "x",
pero "x" vale en este punto
que contiene mi gráfica, es decir,
en este punto que está contenido en mi recta,
vale -12 más "b".
Y bueno, pues lo único que hay que hacer
es resolver esta ecuación para "b",
para encontrar el valor de "b",
que satisfaga esta línea recta.
Y entonces, pues vamos a hacerlo.
Me queda -14/3 es igual ¿a quién?
a 1/3 por -12, menos por más es menos, 12
entre 3 es 4, entonces todo esto se reduce a -4...
y déjame ponerlo con color verde...
-4 más b...
y mejor déjame poner a "b" de color amarillo
para que no nos confundamos,
y quiero hacer todo con mucha claridad,
que todo se entienda paso por paso.
Y bueno, ahora lo que necesito es despejar
a "b" y para despejar a "b", lo que voy a
hacer es sumar 4 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
para que este 4 se cancele con un 4 positivo...
más 4... más 4... y entonces ¿qué me va a quedar?
Del lado derecho, -4 más 4 se van y simple
y sencillamente me queda "b",
mientras que del lado izquierdo
¿cómo opero estos dos quebrados?
Bueno, pues para esto lo que voy a hacer es
encontrar un denominador común y escribir
el 4 con base en ese denominador común,
que es el 3,
y por lo tanto al 4 lo puedo escribir como
12/3, este 4 de aquí es exactamente lo mismo
que 12/3 y entonces me queda 12/3 menos -14/3.
Y quiero ser muy claro en este paso, lo único
que hice fue encontrar un denominador común
y por eso el 4 lo escribí como 12/3.
Y entonces, ¿qué me queda?
12/3 menos 14/3, esto es lo mismo que -2/3,
"b" entonces es lo mismo que -2/3.
¡Y perfecto!
porque ya con este valor de "b", podemos reescribir
esta ecuación y así encontrar la respuesta
de este problema.
Entonces en lugar de "b", voy a sustituirlo
por el valor de -2/3 y me queda que
"y"es igual a 1/3, este 1/3 sale de la pendiente
que nos dieron menos 2/3, porque "b" vale -2/3.
1/3 de "x" menos 2/3 y ¡ya está!
Hemos encontrado la ecuación de esta recta.